alaba ist luca meine freundin ihr sind
bereits sind titel eingeblendet um was
es in dem heutigen video geht die beiden
personen die mit hiermit
sprachen lernen dadurch die beiden
personen die hier gerade mit mir
allerdings sitzen wissen wir nicht worum
es geht oder
hand
die summe ist auch noch dabei
denn was wir heute vielleicht machen
könnten nicht boxen mehr
bringen das mit dem karton richtig ich
habe hier bei ebay eine mystery box
bestellt das heißt wir wissen nicht was
ich hier drin befinden wird jedoch habe
ich für dieses ding sage und schreibe
600 euro
bist du ja und du weißt sicherste
trainer ist angeblich sachen daher waren
wir von 600 euro luca 600 kannst du nur
das iphone kaufen
ja okay von r10 zusammen auch nicht das
ganze jetzt auf jeden fall mal gemeinsam
ausreicht sich auch den ein oder anderen
sachen mit dabei die gut gebrauchen
könnte es gerade zum beispiel durch
fahrten
lukas muss immer alles liebt wie ich
greife jetzt einfach mal rein sie ist
auf jeden fall irgendwas fleisch ist
also
bittet die mal kurz an
ich nehme jetzt mal hier so ein ding
raus fast ein bisschen verpackt ist und
zwar
der ist dass
erst das wollen das potter
wer ist das keine ahnung was denkst du
dir heißt
voldemort ist dass lord voldemort ist
es denn das ist der typ aus der
winkelgasse laos green jobs bank oder
auf diesen teilnehmer zum schächten so
hier sitzen richtiger fan
von laser luke auf instagram instagram
da kommste luca das ist auf jeden fall
geil muss mir keinen adventskalender
kaufen die sache ist allerdings dass wir
direkt weiter macht mit dem nächsten
produkt wir haben wir eine
leidige bisher sind nur geile sachen
drin ja
also ich habe genau das schon ach
ja ja ja ich kann aber nur mensch ärger
dich nicht
bin aber ganz ehrlich gerade nein ich
habe ja es gut ich habe 600 euro dafür
ausgeben und die sachen die ich bisher
ausgemacht aber da gibts halbleer gabe
die kosten ja niemals teil ist das ja
dann kostet ja nicht mal 50 euro im jahr
zusammen ja und die sich schlappen
kosten nicht mehr erklären ich glaub ich
würd mal wieder mein tisch gezogen wir
machen allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten ding was ich hier
habe ich auch immer gesehen was ist ja
auch kopf setzen die sie bisschen aus
wie diese
quelle de vil aus 101 dalmatiner rein
was du dich aussehe wie die gala die im
park saß bei
was
zunächst noch nie geben der leyen stars
gekommen wie ich das immer voll creepy
thema mit dem nächsten produkt freunde
ich gerade erst mal reiten hier sind ein
bisschen kleinere sachen direkt zwei
dinge sogar wir haben einmal
gas an das sind meine kriminalistik und
wir haben
du hast bürsten aufsätze und bekommt
sofort auch irgendeine person sich
gedacht hat mensch ich habe in der
westkaribik auf mein kind voll den ich
haben 300 der spielesammlung haben wir
ihn ja auch gemacht fahrzeuge brauchen
wir nicht meine frau hatte schon welchen
zahn
ich bin ich mich auch nicht warm ihr
weiter mit der nächsten sache und doch
ist doch ein bisschen was dran glaube
ich wir haben nämlich
[Musik]
die süße
die einigung benötigt sie keinen
ausreißer aus mütze oder der helfen ist
richtig gut aus
wie es gibt doch davon will ich sage sie
gar nicht mehr so schnell machen wir
weiter mit dem nächsten produkt und zwar
haben wir hier die verpackung von den
socken
demnächst
so
mit china
aber ich habe auch noch sand was weiß
ich dass die vorhaben mit einem staat
sie
das ist damit macht man sich das
gesichtsmassage
und das
machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt und es war präsentiert die 600
euro gar nicht alter wir haben als
nächstes einen erwachsenen
[Musik]
regel 1
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nach weiter mit dem nächsten produkt
meiner lieben freund
leute das niemals sex und eure werte
bist du dumm du bist so dumm
herbert beste terminiert
[Musik]
junge musik ist ja geil
ja ich habe wachse roma die bringen
übrigens braucht eine neue box nicht die
kostet 100 euro oder so
die kinder sind aber trotzdem noch nicht
bei den 600 mg detail nein verliert
dieses buch lesen man hat einfach meine
box verloren in der türkei von jahr
solle neu gegossen also wenn du willst
dass man dir abkoppelt und nicht ein
bisschen geld macht ihr preis 10 prozent
drauf noch 30
[Musik]
das kann kopf hinter gebrauchen
berichten dass
am
ende zweiter das sieht einfach
dass ich habe meine augen nicht öffnen
was dürfen wir was ich wusste ich dass
es so weit spritzen
fühlt sich an
solche grün
junge dt fast und
das ist das ein vor kondoms sind das
kondom
gleich
was ist das für ein typ ich will gar
nichts mehr anfangen
die verfolger vor der kamera region zum
teil
unter
konto
ja meine lieben freunde welche das
heutige video gefallen hat das auch gern
einen daumen hoch unter dividieren der
abonnieren bei den kanal und fliegt
selbstverständlich auch die
glocke
damit er alle videos verpasst also
klickt auf die glocke und ein video
nicht auf seinen rat